just when you think our media and
scientific establishment can't lose any
more credibility on coronavirus they
come around and surprise you doctor foul
Qi remember doctor foul Qi the exalted
one peace be upon him doctor foul Qi
appeared on CNN yesterday to announce
some excellent news they think they've
got a vaccine but there was a caveat the
vaccine might not be all that effective
I doubt seriously that any vaccine will
ever be 100% protected the best we've
ever done is measles which is 97 to 98%
effective oh that would be wonderful if
we get there I don't think we will I
would settle for 70 75 percent effective
vaccine because that would bring you to
that level of would-be herd immunity
level ok so 70 75 % effective that's not
great obviously you want it to be higher
than that but look as long as we're
gonna get to hurt immunity that's where
you've got you know so many people have
had the virus that you don't need to
worry about it rampaging through the
whole country anymore as long as you do
that I guess that's a good thing so
we're gonna get hurt immunity right dr.
Fauci right dr. Fauci unfortunately
maybe not if only say 70 75 percent of
Americans are willing to get the vaccine
and it's only say I think you just said
70 75 percent effective is that gonna
get us to hurt immunity no unlikely and
that's one of the reasons why we have to
make sure we engage the community as
we're doing now to get community people
to help us for people to understand that
we are doing everything we can to show
that it's safe and that it's effective
and it's for the good of them as
individuals and in society to take the
vaccine so we have a lot of work to do
because as you well know we've spoken
about this intensively in the past there
is a general anti science ant the
authority anti vaccine feeling among
some people in this country an
alarmingly large percentage of people
relatively speaking I can't imagine why
can you imagine why there'd be some
distrust and skepticism of our public
health officials so what he's saying is
that 75% 70 75 percent effective and 70
75 percent of people are going to get it
and if that's all that happens we won't
get hurt immunity which means we may not
get a vaccine even if we do get a
vaccine it won't give us herd immunity
that means the only thing we can do is
flatten the curve to avoid overwhelming
the hospital system which we already did
we've done everything we can and yet for
some reason we're all locking down again
got to tell you something folks feels a
little bit to me like we're being played
for suckers not just on the lock downs
not just in the political arena all the
way over at the Supreme Court too and we
got to wake up because the game seems
stacked against us we'll get into all of
it I'm Michael Knowles us the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back yesterday I asked on
YouTube I mentioned that a lot of
musicians in our changing their names to
be more woke I wanted to know which band
or musician you think will change their
name next to pander to the woke mob
Matthias I felt had the best answer
which is that the Beach Boys are going
to be next because obviously assumes
gender that's very bad and Beach stands
for a place where Noel's ripped on
governor Newsom which is true and I
intend to do that this fourth of July
weekend as well by the way question
today I'd love to hear your thoughts
will the fourth of July be the next
thing to be canceled maybe it already
has been canceled we will get to that in
just a second there has been a lot going
on in the last two days first though
also got to thank our friends over at
blink sail you should not have to waste
time creating ugly invoices in Microsoft
Word you should not have to send nagging
emails to get your invoices paid when
you do send them out you shouldn't have
to worry about getting paid period
that's not not supposed to be your job
that's why our friends over at blink
sail built an invoicing software that
helps you stay on top of your money and
keep track of everything in one place
with blink sale you can send beautiful
custom branded invoices and estimates in
seconds stay on top of your outstanding
invoices this is something when I've
been a freelancer I just forget to send
out invoices I kid you I've missed out
on more money than I care to mention
right now because I haven't stayed on
top of that let your customers and
clients pay your invoices online you'll
even get instant notifications when a
customer opens your invoice so you'll
actually know if they're just avoiding
paying you you don't want that see for
yourself
try blink sale for free at blink sale
comm slash Noel's canna wles that is bli
NK s al e dot comm slash Knowles blink
sale spend less time billing and more
time doing what you love I think we're
being played for suckers folks and I
think some Republican politicians are
being played for suckers to multiple
states now are shutting down again
because of coronavirus I know you might
say Michael why are they shutting their
already
shut down why are they shutting down
again well I'll try to clear that up for
you
yes we shut down for coronavirus
initially that was going to be for 15
days to stop the spread then it became
30 days then 45 days then several months
but then we reopened briefly so that
rioters could tear down our entire
country and knock down statues and burn
buildings and steal property and kill
people so we had to reopen for that
obviously because that served the
left-wing political agenda then though
once the rioters were done once the the
Pride Parade was was over over the
weekend then we had to shut down again
because you can't have people going to
church or Trump rallies or work they can
only go outside if they want to tear
down businesses and tear down monuments
so Arizona and Texas both shutting down
again for covin Texas announced this
about a week ago
very sad Texas was the great hope then
they shut down again and they're all
pretending it has nothing to do with the
riots by the way now Arizona Governor
Doug Ducey is ordering bars clubs movie
theaters water parks and gyms to close
for 30 days in order to curb the spread
of the coronavirus he doesn't get it the
people who are shutting down again don't
get it I mean on a very practical level
they don't even get what the lock downs
are for I do they think that the lock
downs are to stop the virus or to cure
the virus that's not what they're for we
don't have a cure we don't have a
vaccine and foul she just told us we're
not gonna get hurt immunity even if we
do get a vaccine very likely the point
of the lockdowns was to was to extend
the time period over which people would
get infected to flatten the curve as we
used to say to not overwhelm the
hospital system we've already done that
that's over that's done there is no
other purpose to the lockdowns the
lockdowns achieved whatever purpose they
had the only reason now to lockdown is
because you're panicking because you one
don't understand the situation and two
don't realize you're getting played for
suckers the only effect of the lockdowns
at this point will be to harm Trump in
November that's the only reason it's
being pushed okay the one of
the one scientific objective it had it
accomplished now all that's left are
political objectives the longer they
remain locked down the longer the
economy stagnates the more people are
pent up at home the more frustrated they
get the more riots they get the more
likely that Americans are to elect a
comatose Joe Biden president in November
that's all this is about and I'm not
going to play along with it I am going
to ignore the new lockdowns the
reinstituted lockdowns I'm going to
ignore them as best I can I know some
cases the businesses just aren't open I
can't go in but in every other way I am
going to ignore them and I encourage all
of you to ignore them too and I
encourage you to ignore the lockdowns
flamboyantly and flagrantly I want you
to thumb your nose right in the face of
these politicians who either are falling
for this stupid political trap or who
are foisting it on people with
absolutely no basis in medical science
no basis in protecting the public health
all it's doing is effecting a political
agenda LA is following suit LA has just
announced yesterday they're going to
close the beaches for fourth of July
weekend do we think that's gonna stop
the spread of coronavirus first of all
every prediction on coronavirus
particularly in LA has been completely
wrong do you remember now I guess it was
months ago the mayor of LA Eric Carr
said he said there is no world no model
in which Los Angeles doesn't look like
New York within two weeks two weeks came
and went buddy and never got even close
to New York LA has handled coronavirus
completely fine and it's good by the way
it's good to be outside breathing the
fresh air in the sunshine they're
locking down there they are closing for
fourth of July weekend as a political
punishment the only reason that they're
doing this is to be punitive toward
people to flout their power and to gin
up tension in the country they will find
you allegedly if you show up to the
beach in LA with $1,000 now I am
protesting this order in part in the
spirit of these protests because I am a
Sicilian American and I need to go to
the beach to sunbathe so that I can keep
my skin nice and swarthy all right a lot
of anti-italian discrimination going on
these days they're knocking down
Columbus statues and they're not letting
me get my suntan you think I'm joking
about anti-american discrimination in
America
do not forget Italian Americans were the
victims of the largest mass lynching in
American history they don't teach you
that one in the history books do they
kids no they don't but they were the
victims of the largest mass lynching in
American history
it happened in 1891 and it's why in 1892
you had Columbus Day instituted for the
first time as a large holiday in the
United States four hundred years after
the great navigators voyage in part it
was as a way to bring Italian Americans
into the whole American community now
they want to knock that down too
outrageous this is what happens when
people don't study history there is good
news though after my slight digression
I'm anti Sicilian discrimination there
is some good news which is the LA County
Sheriff Alex via Nueva says that he will
not enforce the beach closure order for
the 4th of July he said that the
sheriff's department was not consulted
and they will they will enforce the
closed parking lots and traffic on PCH
which means that PCH is the Pacific
Coast Highway so it's gonna be hard to
get to the beach if the parking lots are
closed but they will not be kicking
people off of the beach which is good
that's a good thing this is what we
should see more of we should see more of
local departments defying their
political overlords we should see
federalism we should see the local
defying the state in the state defying
the federal and we should also see state
governments defying the Supreme Court on
one particular case we saw yesterday
which we will get to in a moment they
are all coming together to push the
narrative again it is so shameless
they told us for three weeks during the
riots and the mayhem and the looting
that coronavirus wasn't a big deal it
was good to gather by the thousands
actually it helped stop the spread of
coronavirus if you protested for
left-wing causes even though it would
encourage the spread of Corona virus if
you protested for right-wing causes and
now shamelessly they're bringing up the
corona virus lockdown again Andrew Cuomo
the most failed governor in America the
guy with the single worst record on
coronavirus his policies responsible for
killing thousands of senior citizens and
nursing homes Andrew Cuomo has the
temerity to go on television during a
press conference and spout off on his
advice to
stop the virus the president can do two
things first sign an executive order
directing everyone to wear a mask how
we're at this point as a nation and we
still haven't done the simple easy
minimal step of saying you must wear a
mask when you are in public and the
president doesn't have to pass a piece
of legislation doesn't have to call the
Congress just sign an executive order
saying wear a mask we did it two months
ago in this state let the president have
the same sense and do that as an
executive order and then let the
president lead by example and let the
president put a mask on it because we
know it works we proven that it works in
the state of New York and the president
can still be New York tough a New York
smart and United and disciplined and
loving if you were only listening to
that clip if you weren't watching it
then you didn't notice that Andrew Cuomo
accidentally gave up the game here which
is he said the president's got a lead by
example
the president's gotta wear a mask put
that mask on be as masks are so
effective and you got to wear them all
the time if you're watching it you might
have noticed Andrew Cuomo he's not
wearing a mask he's now he's not leading
by example what he wants is for the
Republican president to muzzle himself
on television look extraordinarily weak
for the rest of the world and keep his
mouth shut in the process but Andrew
Cuomo gets to spout off Andrew Cuomo
says we instituted certain policies in
New York two months ago well guess what
if you instituted it Cuomo then I don't
want to follow it because whatever
policies you instituted killed thousands
and thousands of senior citizens
needlessly so I don't think we need to
be following mr. Cuomo Slade on any of
this why aren't people wearing masks
more because all of you people told us
not to wear masks for weeks at a time
remember when this started and the
Surgeon General of the United States to
say nothing of all of the journalists
all the politicians they said don't wear
a mask it's bad for you to wear a mask
it will encourage the spread of Corona
virus if you wear a mask then five
seconds later they turn around they say
you
to wear a mask and if you don't wear a
mask you're killing grandma you you have
no credibility man that's that's the
problem you are playing us for suckers
and so I can't believe anything you're
saying and I'm not going to believe
anything you're saying and I'm not gonna
wear that stupid mask unless I'm going
into my favorite restaurants and they
make me but other than that I'm not
going to wear it fortunately people are
waking up to this people are waking up
to this from Ventura County all the way
across the country that gun couple that
was going around the internet we will
get to that in one second first though
got to thank our friends over at
NetSuite you know it's very unfortunate
when a business does not know its
numbers sometimes when a business
doesn't know its numbers the business
goes out of business all you need to
know your numbers is NetSuite by Oracle
the world's number one cloud business
system finance HR inventory ecommerce
you can see everything you need all in
one place so you save time money and
headaches and don't forget time is money
and money sometimes can be headaches
depending on which direction the money
is going in whether you're doing a
million or hundreds of millions in sales
NetSuite gives you visibility and
control so you can manage every penny
with precision join over 20,000
companies who trust NetSuite to go
faster with confidence
NetSuite surveyed hundreds of business
leaders they assembled a playbook of the
top strategies they're using as America
reopens for business go get it right now
receive your free guide seven actions
businesses need to take now and schedule
your free product tour at NetSuite comm
slash Knowles get your free guides
schedule your free product tour RightNow
and NetSuite comm slash Knowles K no W l
es that is NetSuite comm slash Knowles
canna WL es I think a lot of people are
waking up you know there's that line
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me which George W Bush rewrote
to be fool me twice point is you're not
gonna fool me again and people are
waking up to this
slowly but surely nothing like
nationwide riots and statue toppling to
wake you up to a fraud media
establishment that keeps pushing fake
news so this guy
I don't even know his name he's just a
random citizen it's an ordinary fella in
Ventura County walked up during a
council meeting and gave his elected
officials a piece of his mind after
waiting for two hours now getting two
minutes I'll get right to the point
this board is pretending that for the
last three months
your Emperor dr. Lebon has not been
against a mask declaration now all of a
sudden were pretending that masks are
everything even forcing speakers to use
masks I would like the board to take a
position was dr. lemon wrong for those
three months and if he was this wrong
why has he not been removed why has he
not been fired for being so catastrophic
ly wrong or do you not really believe he
was wrong you're just wearing these
masks because it is a signal of your
great virtue because for the last three
months we have not worn them and Burton
Tura County has done outstandingly well
and continues to do outstandingly well
because we are not Los Angeles we are
not in New York City we never were going
to be any of those things never we're
going to be despite predictions to the
contrary and and consider his main point
here on the masks because what the
scientific establishment and the media
and the elected official says yeah we
got something wrong but now we're right
but they're they're not stopping there
they're saying look we once said
something don't wear masks and we
insisted that all of you follow our
advice as though it were the gospel
truth and now we've completely changed
our mind 180 degree flip and we are once
again insisting that you follow us as
though we were telling you the gospel
truth and we'll actually find you and
punish you if you don't follow our
directions exactly that's the problem
people say you're a science denier well
what am i denying am i denying the one
the science that said don't wear a mask
or am i denying the science that saying
do wear a mask science denier as though
it were a religion or or something that
you hold you even more closely and if
there if what they're telling us now is
true that if you walk out without a mask
you're killing grandma
then we sure do need to fire the people
who
told us not to wear masks right we have
to because you're killing gramma if you
don't wear one so the people who told us
not to wear one they got to go we should
maybe prosecute them shouldn't we or
maybe they don't believe it
or maybe they like that CNN reporter who
asked a question of President Trump in
the in the briefing room the minute that
she thought the cameras were off maybe
they take the masks off she didn't
realize one camera was still on caught
her doing that maybe like that MSNBC
reporter came out wearing the mask and
he said people here aren't wearing masks
out on the beach
he was shaming everybody and then one
guy walks up to me says yeah your camera
man's not wearing a mask either they
said that's that's true my camera is no
how are you mask yeah maybe they don't
really believe it
maybe the mask is slipping from the
narrative being pushed by the mainstream
media so the guy makes a great point
there then he goes on and makes a point
about hospitalizations they tell us that
the cases are skyrocketing well is that
really the whole story over 51 total
hospitalizations in a County with eight
hospitals can you people do math can you
please do basic math and understanding
where we are on this this is not a
crisis you have ever have created one
you in an effort to try to prevent all
death but we've had 43 deaths have now
ended all relevant life and you should
all be ashamed of yourselves
and this will never be forgotten ever be
forgotten you will all be held
accountable eventually in this life or
the next
y'all better hope there is no hell
because when you die that's where you're
going and guess what you're not gonna be
dying of colvin either I love this guy I
love him almost as much maybe more
actually as I love that gun couple that
was going around the internet which
which we will get to in a second that's
right people are talking about the case
is exploding well what about the death
rate is the death rate holding if the
death rate is holding and if the number
of deaths is not exploding then we seem
to be in a decent place right because
you've told us that we there's no
vaccine so the only thing we can do is
not overwhelm the hospital system
frankly even if the death rate were not
the death rate but if the number of
deaths were increasing there's still
like nothing we can do according to the
sign
establishment right because we still
don't have a vaccine and the vaccines
not going to give us herd immunity
according to doctor foul Qi the media
here the people who are pushing this
when I say the media I include the
political and scientific establishment
cuz they're all one thing they're all
together foul cheese on CNN and CNN is
setting the narrative and CNN is the
Cuomo family right where the CNN is
Chris Cuomo is Andrew Cuomo it's all one
thing pushing one left-wing narrative
they have no credibility ryan'll is on a
different point other than kovat ryan
lizza who was was tossed out of the
media over over sexual assault
allegations though i guess they weren't
true or something cuz he's back in the
media now back in the White House
briefing room he decided he was going to
use his question for the press secretary
Haley mcenamey
to find out if the President of the
United States
was rooting for the Confederacy in the
civil war that happened over 150 years
ago does he believe this president Trump
believed that it was a good thing that
the South lost the Civil War and then
too is he interested in following NASCAR
first question is absolutely absurd he's
proud of the United States of America
second with regard to our statues
Americans oppose tearing down our
statues there's a Harvard Harris poll
released just last week that shows 60%
of respondents said the statue should
remain and 71% said local governments
should block groups from physically
destroying the statues so he stands on
the side of preserving our history that
woman never ceases to amaze me she has
more composure I think that I would have
had in the event of that question I
think personally if Ryan Lizza
or any other reporter were to ask me or
the President or anybody that question I
think the answer ought to be well Ryan
before I answer that question do you
still beat your wife how do I know you
can't say that how dare you well why the
question I'm asking is just as fair as
is president Trump rooting for the
Confederacy in the war that took place
150 years ago just as fair so just it's
just it's an honest question I'm not
pushing one side of the other Ryan Lizza
do you still beat your wife that I think
would be but Kaley mcenany had a little
more composure she was a little nicer to
him she said that questions ridiculous
and the president doesn't want to topple
statues then though then she twisted the
dagger as she just want to do she
twisted the dagger into the New York
Times pointing out how they have no
credibility how they published a lie
after lie after lie and she got a zinger
in at the end that I just knew I love
and I hope it comes true the president
is briefed on verified intelligence and
again I would just point you back to the
absolutely irresponsible decision of the
New York Times to falsely report that he
was briefed on something that he in fact
was not briefed on and I really think
that it's time for the New York Times to
step back and ask themselves why they've
been wrong so wrong so often the New
York Times falsely claimed Paul Manafort
asked for polling data to be passed
along to Oleg Oleg Deripaska before
having to issue a correction in June of
2017 the New York Times falsely wrote
all 17 Intel agencies had agreed on
Russian interference Barack before
having to issue a correction that it was
only four agencies in 2017 February of
that year New York Times published a
story claiming Trump campaign aides had
repeated contacts with Russian
intelligence which even James Comey has
said was almost entirely wrong New York
Times it is inexcusable
the failed Russia reporting of the New
York Times and I think it's time that
the New York Times and also the
Washington Post hand back their
Pulitzers mic drop see yeah peace out
Kaleigh out love her she's just she is
just tremendous and they should hand
back their pule answers then I mean the
New York Times just won a Pulitzer for
the 16:19 project the central thesis of
which is demonstrably false and has been
proven false by many academic historians
including the supporters of the 16:19
project and the New York Times just
completely ignored that because it cut
against their narrative so they should
hand back their Pulitzers and we should
not grant them any credibility
whatsoever on American history or the
virus or anything else or anything else
the BLM the riots the Supreme Court I
mean any of these issues we should not
grant them any credibility Kaylee also
if this was this was a terrific press
briefing all all in all because one
thing she pointed out was that the
anarchists who are tearing down statues
have increasingly found themselves in
jail hello everyone law and order are
the building blocks to the American
dream but if anarchy prevails this dream
comes Crump comes crumbling down an RP
and our streets is unacceptable and
anger is not enough you have a president
committed to action the DOJ has arrested
over 100 an Argus four rioting and
destruction of federal property the DOJ
has also charged for men in federal
court for attempting to tear down the
statue of Andrew Jackson in Lafayette
Square this is great news and you'll
remember that the Attorney General Bill
Barr mentioned when I sat down with him
last week for the verdict show he
mentioned that these guys were being
arrested there were indictments that
were in Ben
stations more coming and now we're
beginning to see the fruit of that
President Trump was tweeting about it so
it's all happening now this is very good
news more of them should be arrested and
they should be thrown in the can for at
least ten years I think that's that's
the prison sentence for for pulling down
these sorts of statues however that's
not enough right however many are being
indicted and thrown in jail it's not
even close to the hundreds of thousands
of people we saw taking to the streets
looting burning tearing things down and
at the same time we're being told that
we need to defund the police so
unfortunately people need to take their
own safety into their own hands most
people would prefer not to do that okay
I I don't know a single gun owner who
wants to have to go out on his property
and start aiming at roving bands of
anarchists and thugs and looters and
possibly killers I don't know anyone
wants to do that what we'd rather do is
live in nice safe neighborhoods that's
why wealthy people I know the wealthier
they get the safer the neighborhood they
move into okay but when you're being
told that police departments are not
going to get backed up they've got to
stand down people are walking off the
job they're getting defunded the law is
not being enforced well people have to
take their own safety into their own
hands and that's what happened with the
famous the now famous st. Louis gun
couple you might have seen them to me
this should be the the new image and the
Brooks Brothers catalog is this man
walking out in a pink polo shirt and
white chinos with his white tennis shoes
holding an ar-15 and his wife holding a
little I don't know a little tiny cat
like a little James Bond gun or
something I love these guys they're
doing great turns out they're Democrats
I still love them it's okay don't worry
about it what happened hundreds of black
lives matter anarchists trespassed on
private property on their way by the way
to go bother the st. Louis mayor at the
st. Louis mayor's home as these black
lives matter and her kists were marching
through the private property they
destroyed some of that private property
somehow managed to destroy a wrought
iron gate and and possibly some other
stuff so this couple walked out of their
home still on their own property and
they walked out with weapons
here is just a quick clip of the the
wife walking out with her James Bond gun
while the rioters threatened her life
and her property she last night
let's know man you don't for me did you
hear me I said get off my lawn now crazy
go back in the house yeah I blow a hole
in your face and then I go in the house
and I sleep like a baby you can count on
that
we used to stack like you five feet high
in Korea use you for sandbags sorry
sorry that I got confused for a moment
that was actually Clint Eastwood in Gran
Torino but very similar scene you saw
from this woman in st. Louis walks out
with her gun didn't have great trigger
discipline I'm sorry to say but who
cares I mean that's sort of missing the
point when you argue about how she's
holding her gun and whether it's safe or
not
you know what I don't think it's safe
when roving bands of anarchists are
marching through private property I
think actually when when that starts to
happen when the whole country starts
burning down and people are shooting and
looting and killing and stealing then I
don't think we need to be necessarily so
neurotic about exactly how we're holding
the gun I think at that point you're
trying to protect your life and your
livelihood which is exactly what
happened mark and Patricia McCluskey are
their names the way they describe it is
a mob of at least a hundred smashed
through the historic wrought iron gates
of Portland Place destroying them rushed
toward my home where my family was
having dinner outside put us in fear of
our lives of course that's what happened
they're peaceful rioters of course
peaceful they peacefully destroyed
property they've been peacefully burning
down buildings and peacefully tearing
down statues and peacefully killing
people for the last three weeks but they
are peaceful because the people wearing
ties and jackets on the mainstream media
tell me they're peaceful so the city
attorney for for the city Kimberly
Gardner she's the circuit attorney
rather was very upset about this she
said you're not allowed to protect
yourself
she said we must protect the right to
peacefully protest you know like all
those rioters were doing and any attempt
to chill it through intimidation or the
threat of deadly force will not be
tolerated make no mistake we will not
tolerate the use of force against those
exercising their First Amendment rights
to steal stuff and threaten people's
lives and we will use the full power of
Missouri law to hold people accountable
this is it these are the this the
privileged group is black lives matter
and antia and all the
leftist riders they're a privileged
group they have the First Amendment
right to kill you and steal your
property but you a citizen a law-abiding
citizen do not have any rights First
Amendment Second Amendment nothing
you've got to lay down and let these
rioters kill you all in the name of
social justice that according to the
circuit attorney and at that point the
couple has pledged loyalty to black
lives matter it turns out this couple
actually is probably Democrats they've
donated to act blue many times at first
I thought they only pledged fealty to
BLM just so they don't get their
livelihoods destroyed and you know
they're lawyers and obviously they've
got a pretty good life going for them
but it looks like they actually might be
Democrat I don't know if they're
Democrats anymore they might have been
Democrats for the last twenty years but
nothing like a band of anarchists to
wake you up to political reality
regardless of their political views or
they cab to BLM or whatever I give them
credit for defending themselves in the
moment they are completely in the right
these riders are wreaking havoc and
stealing property and killing people all
over the country governments have
defunded the police and the only thing
left to many Americans is self-defense
if you are not defending the st. Louis
gun couple you just don't get it
you just don't get the political
situation that we're in you just don't
get how it's all stacked against you you
think I would assume that just as long
as we play by the lefts rules and we
don't rock the boat too much then we'll
win eventually
a victory for us is just around the
corner just one more judge just one more
judge and we'll win right if you think
that you don't get it you don't get the
situation we'll get to that one more
judge issue we'll get to the Supreme
Court just one second first though I've
got to thank you I got to thank you
because what started a couple weeks ago
with me just wanting to work my friend
drew Clavin and beat him in the youtube
subscribers has now exploded we've flown
past 100,000 subscribers thank you for
that thank you for as subscribing to the
mikonos youtube channel please also
subscribe to the Michael Knowles show
podcast where ever you listen to
podcasts we're actually currently number
21 on the podcast charts we beat pods
save America yesterday we flew up past
them now I think they're at 20 or so I
don't know
they're pro gaming the system so
certainly please help me beat pod save
America and then right now Ben then is
at number 10 and I I really want to beat
Ben on the charts I really I you know
look guys I don't ask for much
I really I really want to be been on the
charts so please that go over there
subscribe leave a five star review we'd
appreciate it you know we have lots of
fun bonus content all over the place I
just did a interview with my friend Dan
bond Gino and Ruben and lots of other
stuff also speaking of Ben the left will
stop at nothing to destroy the American
Way of life they are what Ben calls
disintegration astern of segregations
their disintegration is in his new book
how to destroy America in three easy
steps you can pre-order it at daily
wire.com slash Ben or even find it on
Amazon or Barnes and Noble all over the
place
covers the two fundamentally different
visions for America
Ben Ben covers all of this in his book
how to destroy America in three easy
steps pre-ordered it daily wire.com
slash Ben I feel like then writes a new
book every week or so but he can do it I
know the guy's a robot he's just he is
able to churn that kind of content
always very interesting stuff head on
over there we'll be right back with a
lot more
we just got to play by the left rules
and then we'll win but don't rock the
boat too much look we have a fair shake
we just we need to win one more election
got to nominate just one more judge and
then we'll start winning back the
culture and the institutions and our
political establishment right wrong
that's not that's not what's going to
happen and if you still believe that
that's the case you have not been paying
attention yesterday we got more evidence
of this in a Supreme Court decision June
medical services versus Russo this
centered on whether or not Louisiana
could put into place
any restrictions on abortion eseni basic
health restrictions so here was the
restriction in in Louisiana they said
that because the left is saying that
abortion is just a regular medical
service and abortionists are just
regular health service providers then
those abortionists needed to have
admitting privileges at a local hospital
they're just holding the abortionists to
the same standards they would hold any
other medical professional as we are
being told abortionists are just medical
professionals obviously they're not but
that's what the leftist things we say
okay
by your own premise we're just saying
that they have to be safe they got to
have admitting privileges in a hospital
not allowed to do that not allowed to do
that not allowed to hold the left to its
own standards the left has double
standards if they didn't have double
standards that have no standards at all
well hold on I thought we had a
conservative court and this is so
obvious of course Louisiana can can
regulate its medical servicers its
medical providers to have to be
certified right they can they obviously
can force medical providers to have to
have admitting privileges can't they no
no because it might threaten that
sacrosanct a sacred right enshrined an
invisible link in the Constitution that
gives a mother a right to kill her child
where is it in the constant no I would
no one's been able to point it out to me
but it's somewhere in there apparently
how did we how did we get such an
egregious decision we have a
conservative court don't we not John
Roberts Bush appointee conservative
judge remember same guy who upheld
Obamacare on bogus
reasoning john roberts decided to say
that because of past precedent because
there have been so many bad abortion
decisions already then the doctor of
story decisis meaning you give deference
to precedent forces them to treat those
cases alike and louisiana law imposes a
burden on access to abortion and so
therefore louisiana can't do that and
roberts had the temerity to invoke
edmund burke edmund burke is the sort of
first modern conservative philosopher he
thinks there should be evolution not
revolution things should proceed slowly
we should give some credence to
precedent this is a lot like neo Gorsuch
invoking scalia in his outrageous
decision two weeks ago burke has nothing
to do with this
even story decisis has nothing to do
with this in fact as we saw in the
dissent it's exactly the opposite the
idea of of this Burkean conservative
give give deference to the wisdom of the
ages only works if you are allowed to
change things over time but what Roberts
said is no because we had like one bad
decision way way back we have to let
them decide our law for the whole whole
rest of the future really what they
wanted what Roberts wants is to maintain
the liberal establishment because he
doesn't want to rock the boat at all he
wants to play by the rules and he wants
to manage the decline of America just as
Thomas a great guy great judge he put it
simply he said our abortion precedents
are grievously wrong and should be
overruled simple enough and it reminded
me of another story there's a story that
the AP just put out Associated Press and
they put it out without a byline and
they put it out without a byline because
they don't want their journalists to be
killed by the Chinese communist
government which does that sort of thing
and the article was was critical of
China said China cuts Weger births with
IUDs abortion and sterilization China
cuts the week of its China's killing
this weaker population that put them in
concentration camps that use them for
slave labor the weaker czar these
Muslims who are living in China China is
committing a genocide against them right
now through contraception IUDs abortion
sterilization
why is that bad why is it bad that why
is this a bad thing so bad that it's
newsworthy the AP is gonna write about
it so damaging to China that the
journalists are afraid for their lives
that they won't even put their name on
the article why is it bad this is we're
doing the same thing the United States
is doing the exact same thing we have I
you DS we got abortion people sterilize
themselves what's the issue then well
the issue here what they would say is
well it's about consent you see the we
Gers aren't consenting to to killing
their babies whereas in America people
do consent to killing their babies and
so it's good when it when Americans do
it and bad when the Chinese government
doesn't consent that's the only thing is
that the only category that we can
possibly speak about with with any moral
discourse this reminds me of arguments
during slavery the arguments during
slavery before the the Civil War were
that it was this question of slavery was
really one of states rights but then
that next question became clear which is
states rights to do what states don't
have the right to do anything states
rights to do what people's consent to do
what if conservatives want to have any
chance of reclaiming any power in this
culture we need to move past this
shallow question of mere consent well as
long as you choose to do it you can do
whatever you want
that's all I'm just for choice I'm
pro-choice yeah the choice to do what we
need to be able to have a substantive
moral and political dialogue otherwise
conservatives they're the conservatives
actually have nothing to offer right
there's no surprise that the Liberals
would have taken over the entire culture
and politics and institutions is they
offer something they offer a substantive
moral vision it's a it's a terrible one
but it's still a moral vision I mean
consider Margaret Sanger Margaret Sanger
the patron saint of Planned Parenthood
who's taught is a wonderful American in
school so there's a bust of her in the
Smithsonian I believe Margaret Sanger
will most wicked women in American
history
talk about statues that should come down
no one no one ever seems to tear down
her statue Margaret Sanger off
a substantive moral vision about
abortion about life that is perverse
it's exactly the opposite of reality but
listen listen to her vision for life not
so different than the see see see the
Chinese Communist Party not so different
from the left today do you believe in
sin
when I say believe I don't need to
believe in committing sin do you believe
there is such a thing as a sin I think
the greatest sin in the world is
bringing children into the world that
have we disease from their parents that
have no chance in the world to be a
human being
practically delinquents prisoners all
sorts of things just mark when they're
born that to me is the greatest sin that
people can have become commit but still
in the ordinary sense that we regard it
do you believe or do you not believe do
you believe it infidelity is a sin well
I think I'm not gonna specify but I
think it's in our state if I think it's
the worst then yes then you asked me to
say what and Ike and I said what and I
and you refuse to answer me I don't know
about infidelity it has many
personalities to it and what person's
own belief is you can't
I couldn't generalize any of those
things
consider the perversity of that this is
one of the great heroes of the American
left and and really you know consider
the great hero of Planned Parenthood
she says that the worst sin in the world
is letting people live the worst sin in
the world is not killing people and then
the interviewer Mike Wallace says what
about all the sins that we consider sins
you know like you know violating the Ten
Commandments that sort of that
adulteries oh I don't know about that I
can't talk about adultery well of course
not because if for this woman the
highest virtue is killing people I
suppose the highest virtue for her would
be consent to do all of these terrible
things she is offering I mean it truly a
satanic vision of the world saying that
the worst thing you can do is let human
beings live but that is a moral vision
we need to oppose that with an opposite
moral vision if we don't do that then we
then we are consenting to the left
running roughshod over the whole culture
and frankly we deserve what we get if
we're not willing to actually stand
and oppose it we are being played for
suckers they give you one last example
of this before we have to head out for
the day there they're pushing for
nationwide mail-in votes that that not
not just that if you're out of town or
you know you're deployed or something
then you can mail in your vote but for
everybody so that no one has to go to
the polls because of the corona virus
which is super duper deadly and a kill
all of us unless you want to go riot or
go to a pride parade then you're immune
from corona virus but everyone else you
know you're if you go to church or
something then you're gonna catch it you
know that one so they're trying to push
for mail-in ballots for everybody the
Attorney General as we were speaking
last week and other other people in the
administration pointed out this is going
to lead to widespread voter fraud the
left denies it they say there's no voter
fraud no voter fraud with mail and
balance never happens by the way in Los
Angeles now when you when you get your
mail-in ballot because they've sent you
can opt-in they send you one it'll say
your political party on the outside of
the envelope it'll taste there's that
like a big sign in Los Angeles that says
throw out this ballot this is a
Republican there was one time I showed
up I voted in the primary and the
Republican probably one of the few
Republicans in my neighborhood in LA and
I showed up in the general election I
had been purged from the voter rolls I
just wasn't there
this happened to two other Republican
friends of mine which constitutes I
think about 75% of the LA Republican
population there are all these anecdotes
people hear these stories all the time
about craziness going on at the ballots
this is this has been true of politics
for all of history but we know that it's
happening we know it's happening
specifically with mail-in ballots the
New Jersey Attorney General Gorby er s
Gris wall just filed criminal charges
against four individuals including to
City Council officials last week I guess
two weeks ago now for allegedly engaging
in voter fraud with mail-in ballots
those people are Michael Michael Jackson
not that one he's first word councilman
and council vice president of Paterson
New Jersey he's a left-winger Alex
Mendez of Paterson chalene colleague of
Wayne New Jersey and Abu rate rezian of
Prospect Park I think those were just
the two operatives you add the voter
fraud the mail and voter fraud being
committed by elected officials you know
the very
I'm elected officials who are now
telling you that there is no worry about
voter fraud if we go to a full mail-in
ballot don't worry there's no big what
you don't want people to vote what
you're against people voting what are
you some kind of racist or something
that's what they're telling you they're
playing you for suckers don't let them
do it if we are not willing to offer a
substantive vision and if we are not
willing to exercise the political power
that we have the little tiny bit of
political power we have when we have it
then what's the point if we're not
willing to do that I guess we just don't
get it all right that's our show I'm
Michael Dell's as the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
Boren supervising producers Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling technical
producer Austin Stephens assistant
director pavel madoski editor and
associate producer danny D'Amico audio
mixer robin fenders hair and makeup
nikka geneva production assistant ryan
love the michael knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
you